and even everyone
for coming out on such a
evening to spend it inside listening to
talk on Russia my name is Gerald Stang
I'm editor-in-chief of the journal of
international affairs and on behalf of
the editorial and faculty advisory
boards of the journal and of our
co-sponsors at the Harriman Institute
I'm happy to welcome you to our event
launching our spring/summer issue on
rethinking Russia tonight's event also
coincides with the launch of our new
website which will provide a platform
for our network of contributors to write
about issues that go beyond just the
themes that we have in the print issue
of the journal and will soon also have
up on site all of the back issues for
the journal of international affairs
going back to nineteen forty seven the
evenings events will start with talks by
each of our panelists and followed by a
moderated discussion among them and
ending with a question and answer period
from the audience this evening's event
is being recorded and will be viewable
on our website later and after where the
event is over we invite you to join us
in the foyer outside for some wine and
Russian cuisine now for the first few
decades of the journals existence Russia
made regular appearances on our pages
from our 1954 issue on post-war Soviet
foreign policy to our 1989 issue on
Gorbachev's new era of thinking and many
times in between the Soviet Union was
the subject of articles in the journal
in the 20 years since the end of the
Cold War however Russia has rarely been
present in the journals pages that's why
we're particularly excited to launch
this evening's event and our Russia
issue with a panel that has such depth
of experience reaching back into the
Soviet era but also with a keen
understanding of Russia's position in
the world today we're also very pleased
to have Katrina vanden heuvel here
tonight as moderator for the event she's
the publisher and editor of the nation
magazine the old is the oldest
continuously published weekly in the
United States in her career at the
nation she has spent considerable time
in the USSR and Russia and among other
books she is the co-editor with one of
our other panelists Stephen F Cohen of
voices of glasnost interviews with
Gorbachev's reformers she's a frequent
commentator on American and
international politics and her articles
have appeared in The Washington Post the
LA Times the New York Times and many
other prestigious places she will
introduce the rest of our
panel mrs. Van Google welcome Thank You
gerald it's an honor to be here as
editor of a weekly now 24-7 the nation
com as well it's always been important
to read the scholarly journals to find
where the ideas are coming from the
creative new ideas so I enjoyed I will
admit I haven't gone through the entire
journal but I want to say that I am
going to be in touch with two of the
women who wrote about civil society
because I think that's an important
article in terms of taking on a
caricature of Russia we too often see in
the mainstream media but the nation for
better or worse as Gerald said has long
made russia one of its major topics and
even though we may not have gotten it
quite right we've been around 145 years
during certain periods of Soviet history
I do think we through analysis reporting
and voices from Russia so important and
represented in the journal here I do
think we humbly got the Gorbachev era
right and that to me is important the
topic of this issue I'm so glad you call
this rethinking Russia and not reset
with Russia a term we've heard so much
of the topic of rethinking Russia is
very close to my heart because one of
the panelists full disclosure not only
my co-author but my husband Stephen F
Cohen has been rethinking the Soviet
experience the Russian experience and
many other experiences for much of his
life and time so since I've heard it all
before from Steven I'm going to give him
five minutes not ten no I'm kidding me
very pleased to be here though with this
very knowledgeable panel with
wide-ranging interests and expertise the
plan is for the panelists to speak for
10 minutes then have a brief exchange
amongst themselves and then open it up
to you and if you would come up to the
mic
would make it easier I'm not sure if
you're taping doing all kinds of things
in this new multimedia content world but
let me start i'm going to start from my
left my normal position my left and go
Steve then Nina and then Lincoln and
steve has a wide-ranging issue interview
in this issue and he's going to talk
about the conflicting views of Russia's
proper place in the world and that
debates relationship to an ongoing
struggle here in this country and how US
policy toward Russia may affect the
outcome Nina Chris Java welcome we'll
talk about what she considers the
surprisingly liberalizing effect of the
economic crisis on Russia's relations
with for example Poland kyrgyzstan
Ukraine and Lincoln Mitchell talk about
how American elites and non elites view
Russia and how this contrasts with how
Russia is viewed in its own near abroad
let me just briefly introduce them all
together and then we can have a seamless
flow of discussion as steve is professor
of Russian studies and history at NYU
and professor of politics emeritus at
Princeton University his books include
blue heron and the Bolshevik Revolution
rethinking the Soviet experience failed
crusade America and the tragedy of
post-communist Russia and most recently
soviet fates and lost alternative some
stalinism to the new Cold War his latest
book a version of which has already been
published in Russia is the victims
return survivors of the gulag after
Stalin which will be published in this
country in August nina krilova is a
societal in the graduate program of
international affairs at the new school
and senior fellow of the world policy
institute she's also an editor and a
contributor to Project Syndicate an
association of newspapers around the
world
she's had a two-year appointment as a
research fellow at the school of
historical studies of the Institute for
Advanced Studies in Princeton and is the
author of imagining Nabokov Russia
between art and politics and it's
currently working on a new book Russia's
gulag of the mind a lot of gulag Lincoln
Mitchell is an associate at Columbia
University's Herman institute from 2006
to 2009 he was the Saltzman assistant
professor forgive me I've lost my oh you
can look it up online I'm sorry what I
do know Lincoln has written and spent a
lot of time in Georgia and he is
particularly interested in the
perception of Russia both in this
country and in the near abroad he has
done a lot of work with the National
Democratic Institute and we were talking
most recently in the quote green room
about his trip to up a posi aware he has
done a report which has been issued but
he is at work on a longer piece for a
whirl policy journal with your colleague
professor Cooley so Steve over to you
well I always travel with my own
moderator sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't that's my advantage
my disadvantage is is that none of my
glasses work the ones I'm wearing and
the ones here so i may stop for a minute
and change glasses I got to say that I
once spoke in this room a long time ago
and I have this memory of it I think
it's the least deep and widest room I
ever spoken and people persistence
sitting on the two wings so you kind of
cause I remember going home with a stiff
neck so i may just talk back there I
like the question I was given a lot how
does post-soviet Russia see itself in
the world today but I don't think the
questions properly formulated
it's important but we have to ask it
correctly first of all what the Russian
people think doesn't matter or matters
only on the margins just as what
American people think about American
foreign policy doesn't matter very much
what matters is the Russian political
class of the elite by which I mean the
politicians and the policy intellectuals
moreover that political class is very
very deeply divided it was deeply
divided when the Soviet Union existed
about the Soviet Union's proper role in
world affairs but since the end of the
Soviet Union those divisions have become
very conflictual I would say and now
this is something we ought to keep in
mind that its policy debates the policy
debates within that political class are
far more diverse wide-ranging and
substantive in some ways and are the
policy debates in our own political
class about foreign policy that may
surprise you but I believe it to be true
very gently generally there are three
fundamentally different conflicting
points of view in the Russian political
class about Russia's future and world
affairs all of these groups these three
groups agree that Russia is is Russian
intellectuals like to say doomed to be a
great power but they disagree about what
that means and how Russia should go
about coming and remaining a great power
the first group only because it no
longer exists for all practical purposes
but once was important is what can
simply be called the pro-american
faction in Russian politics its view was
after 1992 that Russia's road to great
power and significance in the world was
as a junior partner of the United States
it equated the United States with the
West and it believed that Russia had no
good future militarily culturally
politically economically apart from the
West this group had probably the single
most important influence as a political
faction in Kremlin policymaking from
about 1992 to about 1995 1996
since then it's been killed killed by
American policy toward Russia and I
should say about Russia's tradition it's
simply not compatible with Russia's
tradition it exists in the form of few
intellectuals it's no longer a force I
don't think it can be revived the second
geopolitical of school of thought in the
Russian political class argues that
Russia tried this pro-western
orientation from about 1992 to about the
early 20th century and it nearly
destroyed Russia if the result was a
catastrophe Russia hooked itself to the
west or tried to and the result was
beginning in 1985 to the early 20th
century collapse conquest loss of power
military encirclement and exploitation
therefore this point of view now goes
back to that older Russian tradition
that stretches from the Slava vials in
the 18th century to Joseph Stalin that
Russia has to turn away from the West
Russia's security lies in the East
particularly with China and with any
other any NATO and non NATO country
ready to ally with Russia the farther
Russia is from the west and the least
the less Russia has to do with the West
in this view the more secure the more
influential the more strong the more
Russian Russia will be so that's a kind
of extreme view on the other side the
third group is kind of in the middle in
that it takes this concept of Eurasian
ISM which the second group also
professes it takes it literally it
accepts the view the reality that Russia
geopolitically is both in Europe and in
Asia and in this it sees Russia's future
but it makes an important distinction it
argues that America is not relevant here
America is not a European country
America is not the West Europe is the
West as far as Russia's related America
at most now for Russia is a nuisance a
problem as we used to say about Russia
to be managed
but there's nothing particularly
valuable that the United States has
economically politically there Russia
needs any longer this group sees
Russia's future in a dual policy one
face to the west one face to the east
and this policy is a course associated
with Putin and its triumph in the view
of this policy are the two most
important rapprochement adei that's me
speaking they are the most important
that's Moscow's rapprochement Earl in
and repair small with Beijing and this
is the future of Russia I think it's
exceeding important the the political
class is represented by Putin deeply
believes in it they think it's proved
itself it has growth possibilities may
be right may be wrong but that's
certainly the trend in Russia let me end
by saying a very briefly for the sake of
discussion for concluding remarks about
this whether we like it or not and
Washington still tends to make its
policy or at least think about policy
based on some pro-american group in
Russia that group no longer exists as a
political reality the real struggle in
Russia is between the other two now both
sides believe that Russia is entitled to
a sphere of influence or a zone of
privileged interest however you put it
in the old Soviet territories they do
not disagree about that but they
disagree about what exactly that means
there are different this is an ongoing
debate in an interesting one thirdly
this struggle over foreign policy and it
is a struggle is now linked to this
debate this renewed debate on how to
modernize Russia all sides agree that
Russia is in ruins it's a resolution its
infrastructures need to be rebuilt
quickly and the debate has developed as
many of you know between to take the two
sort of opposing views that this should
be done as Russia has always done it
from Peter it's a stolen by the state
and the other view that it should be
done in a new way for Russia
that Gorbachev tried that semi failed
should be revived that is in a kind of
European Western evolutionary but
participatory way the two are obviously
linked the debate over foreign policy
and the debate over domestic policy and
I would end simply with this lament that
American policy toward Russia since the
end of the Soviet Union has abetted the
worst elements in this debate it's it's
given them the argument that Russia
doesn't have time to do anything
democratically including the modernizing
the country and it's a better the view
that Russia cannot trust the West
whether it's the United States or Europe
at particular United States so the
outcome of this won't be decided by us
but American policy will certainly
perform a context and at the moment that
context is not good but that too is a
debate in Moscow whether or not American
policy has actually changed under Obama
or not they're not sure and probably
some others in this room aren't sure
either but that's where things stand I
think
good evening I'm a form bill firm
believer that Russia is a western
country I just want to say we clear and
clean right here in and now so who lost
Russia was a very notorious question for
quite a while and I believe it has
recently been replaced weather once
improbable one is Russia changing not
long ago Russia likely to respond to the
global financial crisis and the response
was seen as possible was too predictable
which was the Russians would feel
cheated on prosperity so newly won and
the nation will take to the streets and
the Kremlin that would have to tighten
its grip on power in response there was
an alternative scenario the Kremlin is
forced to give up its power and with a
new leadership will start in you and
with something like the thaw that Nikita
Khrushchev experienced in 1950s or me
Hal Gorbachev spirits throat romantic
80s would ensue in Russia will start its
cycle all over again the letter hasn't
happened but neither does did the former
in the past confronting a deep economic
crisis Russia usually tend to move from
totalitarianism to great liberalism but
usually those forces would be moved
forward by the changing of the guards
this opening two more freedom never
actually appeared to have a long lasting
result and hence we have the phenomenon
of ledom a Putin because he after is
humane presidency in 2000 as we all know
really try to dismantle yeltsin's quest
for democracy I mean of course the quest
was not perfect and democracy was even
less and still for almost a decade
Putin's managed democracy
remember it was used to describe it this
way I would call it straitjacket
democracy was really not troubling the
public at all the public so only the
government the government involvement in
the growing prosperity and that high oil
prices really assisted that quite a bit
so the growing economy really made the
ordinary Russians willing to curtail the
freedoms because it C was seeing like a
trade off for a better life when oil
prices from plummeted in the wake of the
crisis in the fall of two thousand eight
the newfound prosperity was endangered
and the economy economy's growth was
halted so the government budget that
mushroomed in the years of high oil
prices fell into deep deficit and a
balanced budget actually now it has been
calculated would now require the prices
that would steadily be at hundred and
ten dollars a barrel it may happen me
know i have a now it's at 86 so it's
better than it was a year ago but still
north hundred and ten and not steadily
so Russia's political centralization
suggested that the government response
to economic crisis and economic
uncertainty would hope follow historic
pattern which was as we all know led the
state one more things and following
Putin's crumble anization in Kremlin
ization not criminalization but
basically all the same of the energy
sector in the year of 2008-2009 economy
saw greater stewardship of many elements
and many elements of the economy and the
Kremlin oversight really only delivered
greater inefficiency the expectation was
that the dead hand of the state was
again dooming russia's economy to that
quarters midterm innovative came to
power was installed in the kremlin in
2008 who
protg and at the time was believed and
I still believe it is true he meant to
serve just one purpose he was too soft
to soften they now Prime Minister
Vladimir Putin's tough rhetoric and sort
of slightly to blur the autocratic image
that Russia had before 2008 he indeed
was saying all the right things he's
still saying all the right things when
he moved into the Kremlin he dams
corruption he attacks legal nihilism he
talks about resource curse and argues
that the civilizing influence of
modernization Western westernization
will do wonders for Russia ideology
nonetheless for quite a while changed
little and I don't want to beat a dead
horse but since Mikhail Khodorkovsky and
the Yukos oil company has been a great
example all the time but I still want to
get that example because it is the most
glaring one no rhetoric won't change
that that hydroxy continues to be in
prison going through his second trial
and yet in recent month Medvedev's
civilizing rhetoric appears to be paying
off and Russia's response to the
financial crisis recently has become
less Atta cratic and not more what a
surprise first Moscow was able to inject
massive amounts of liquidity into
Russian economy and one thing that Putin
has gotten right with the help of his
finance minister Lisa Kudrin was that
use the Stabilization Fund that there
was put away hundreds of millions from
the oil wealth when when it had all
wealth now for a rainy day and this is
shirred one big thing that no major
banks collapsed and minor banks failures
were really administered in a rather
orderly fashion and more importantly
defying all expectations they have been
no major nationalizations of private
companies but what happened is with the
ordinary Russians the return of hard
times means that they
former or the inconvenient i would say
undemocratic facts that they were
ignoring during the years of economic
growth now began to bubble up the
surface and suddenly people who want
completely want to complain and are
concerned about the free speech because
they have things to say and they
increased legal and justices all of a
sudden trouble them and rampant official
corruption as an issue and police
brutality and rigged elections now have
become a huge problem for this for the
for the state there was a really
interesting event that started having in
March it's called Putin to step down
campaign its Human Rights Internet
campaign and sulfide his collected forty
thousand forty thousand signatures which
may not sound like a lot may not seem a
lot in the country of 140 million people
but for a population cowed by Putin it's
actually a big step forward because so
many people put their names to call him
to resign and at that this undoubtedly
spooked the regime then they has been a
steady stream of weekly protests all
across Russia in Moscow st. Petersburg
and blood vessel Ingrid and and many
other cities then there was Moscow
Subway's bombing as you remember in
April and the lady explosions in the
Sullivan Russia all this are a sign that
one silence chechen militants are now
testing Putin as well and for the first
time since 2000 the regime sees a
genuine threat to its monopoly on power
pootin certainly knows our that at least
for a while the almighty driven
popularity popularity and over and there
is seems to be growing understanding
today that to reverse the economic
downturn liberal ideas may need to be
implemented Russia is finally waking up
to the idea that in the 21st century
just like it was the Communist slogan
that that ultimately failed you cannot
build communism and one separately taken
country you really cannot fight the
global crisis on one's own Madhvi defend
President Barack Obama signing last
month of the long-range nuclear weapons
treaty is a step in the right direction
I know they've been a lot of debate what
it means what it means go when this
thing was happening and until the last
minute there was sort of information
that maybe the Russians would decide not
to we haven't gotten enough from the
Americans and yet they did sign so I
actually think it was a tremendously big
deal even in in terms of goodwill in
another sign of an improving climate
Putin after 70 years finally admitted to
the stile and arrow massacre of the
22,000 poles during World War two and in
a tragic accident as you know a few days
later president lech kaczynski in ninety
five other people were killed they were
on the way to to the memorial service
and that led to the unprecedented
warming in the Polish Russian relations
which I believe is it is an a tremendous
step forward in fact the Polish Russian
access is if it does work out can lead
to can be key to Russia's modernization
there was another very recent debate
whether it will demean Russia's great
standing unique standing in the world if
the Allied forces could March with the
Russians in the parade marking the 65th
anniversary of World War two and so the
first idea that only the Russians could
nobody else could because then what our
friends now finally everybody is
marching and this once again is a
tremendous sign so far the economic
crisis has been really good for Russia
for its civilized makeover and Alexander
Hetson the Russian think of one sin
disorder will save Russia and it is true
throughout Russian history crisis did
bring revolutions and open change of
power just think of the Bolsheviks of
the 17 or then
Yeltsin on the tank in 1991 but in a
historical and unusual turn about the
Kremlin is now working to prevent
disorder it is trying to act as its own
reformer and this is sort of a throw
away metaphor and please forgive me I
think it's very exaggerated but that's
how I think about this just imagine if
Joseph Stalin decided to become
Khrushchev and initiated his own
discipline ization thank you a pleasure
to be here on the 15th floor um I want
to begin by making a bit of a confession
which for those of you who is you only
got a kind of truncated version my bio
I'm not really a Russia specialist right
and I want to think I should know that
going in my observations today I study
kind of the rest of the region obviously
I particular attention to Georgia but
most of my work and most of my research
is on the rest of the region so I in a
perfect world that gives me some
interesting perspective and an imperfect
world that gives me ignorance and we're
hoping to kind of get that sweet spot
right in the middle here um so we'll see
how this goes but I believe that that
the question of how Americans view
Russia is important both how elite
Americans the political class but also
how ordinary Americans view Russia and
it's also the end how those opinions are
formed and it's not something to which
we give a lot of thought and I will just
add that what I'm going to say today is
largely based on impressions rather than
actual research I haven't really gone
out and done focus groups and you know
done interviews but i think i spent
enough time around in the policy world
and also in the rest of the world to get
a sense of this um i want to focus on a
fuse particular things one is how
important Russia is to most Americans
secondly how much of American feelings
toward the Cold War kind of toward
Russia are kind of left over from the
Cold War and lastly the extent to which
Russia is a partisan issue among the
higher levels of American politics and
the conclusion is going to focus a
little more on a lead issues of how the
country's how views of each other affect
affect the relationship between the
so first how do Americans think of
Russia and and the answer here I think
as we all know is pretty straightforward
they don't write ordinary American folks
just don't think of Russia once they
most they still say things like the
Soviet Union when you tell when I tell
people I'm going to Georgia they say Oh
Russia Georgia and I say no not exactly
right um so there's not a lot of
attention paid to it it's um it's it's
not somebody there's kind of on people's
you know the way people might think
about Afghanistan or Iraq or something
and in fairness it's not a tier 1
foreign policy issue to the United
States right at the policy level it's
important to be sure it's not as
important as a rack it's not as
important as Afghanistan it's not as
important as Iran it's it's not as
important in terms of bilateral
relations it's not as important as China
yeah I think that if we take a step back
we may think maybe Mexico is actually
pretty important to now it's not a
matter of ranking you know which which
policy crisis is more important or less
important than the next one but it does
is important to have a sense of
perspective on this I think it probably
accurately described as a second-tier
policy concern of major countries that
are not just kind of friendly like you
know you know your kingdom or something
it's kind of perhaps our second most
important or stressful my lateral
relationship the first obviously is
China the first bilateral relationship
and of course this all occurs in an era
which is dominated by non-state actors
and non-state threats right and perhaps
one where because of that we've lost a
little bit of our sense of how to work
with bilateral relationships um now this
creates a problem for the us-russia
relationship right it's hard to really
engage with the contrary if at the end
of the day the elites don't think it's
all that important and the ordinary
people don't don't don't think about it
at all especially when certainly for
some of things we've discussed today
it's not it's far from obvious that
that's the view in Russia there may be
some people the third group perhaps hold
that view of the United States but
general that there's something of an
asymmetry there I think that's that's
kind of obvious what also strikes me is
that when you go when you talk to people
from the rest of the region that
asymmetry plays itself out
also so I very I mean and produced a
certain pathology of Georgia but you get
it in the rest of the region as well in
Eastern Europe or your you see this
little through articles and through
personal conversations with leadership
where you constantly hear doesn't the
United States understand that the Russia
is the biggest threat to world peace and
the answer is no the United States
really doesn't understand that the
United States doesn't believe that and
if you I don't know picked up a paper or
opened up a major news website in the
United States sometimes in the last
decade or so you might see ample
evidence as to why the United States
doesn't let's see that but but but that
does create tension in our relationship
with some of our allies in the rest of
the region right um the United States is
not focused on Russia being a threat as
a primary foreign policy and if you're
sitting in Tbilisi or rigo or somewhere
you are and and and the difficulty of
understanding why America doesn't see it
that way obviously at the higher levels
presumably they do but but it's not so
simple and I think these frequent
warnings of the threat of Russia if you
are sitting in tube leases or Riga or it
may not necessarily be so much wildly
inaccurate as they're completely tone
deaf to what's going on in the United
States right um having said all that the
Cold War legacy is a deep one and it's
it's not hard to mobilize anti-russian
feelings in the United States you don't
have to push too hard to do that right
particularly if you're in a presidential
campaign and you're losing right but but
I want to just give one example I was
out to dinner a couple of weeks after
the Georgia Russia war in 2008 had
started and ended with a 19 year old
Georgian American who was serving and is
still serving in the United States
military but is Georgian and has a
Georgian name and grew up in Tbilisi and
and and why said to him you know what
what are your peers what are your
colleagues say to you about about this
conflict you know this is your country
that's involved here and he said well
you know he's a kid so right so he says
I get all these notes on my Facebook
page from my colleagues in the military
I don't know how that Facebook works in
the military whether it's different
Facebook or regular Facebook and all of
them are basically saying things like
we're with you you know let's go win
let's go fight in got your back
and again we're talking about a young
person who's not that high up in the
military's 19 or 20 now but they're 21
now I guess but the point is that that
energy is not hard to tap in the
American political psyche even at the
grassroots level during this the talk of
the new Cold War right which is I don't
know perhaps a cut above reset in terms
of kind of tired clichs about the
us-russia relationship but one of the
interesting things about it is it's
often discussed with both the sense of
inevitability and a sense of almost
happiness right there was a New Yorker
cartoon with a conference room in a
general with you know all the badges on
his on his chest saying and a couple
guys like a caricature of kind of
military industrial complex in the
general says ah a new Cold War it's like
slipping on a comfortable old shoe um
Cold War wasn't really such a
comfortable old shoe and slipping it
back on may not be the best idea in the
world nonetheless there are still elite
there are still cold warriors and
leadership positions for whom they
anti-russian not just at the grassroots
level but for whom that anti-russian
view is is absolutely second nature and
and and part of that which is a is is is
that the narrative of the USSR has
changed over since the end of the USSR
so that part of that narrative now is
that this was and it's not question and
exercise and Russian imperialism right
which of course there are strong
elements I mean that's not it's not
wildly inaccurate but it does it does
position the rest of the countries in
the region in a different way relative
to that narrative relative that history
relative to Russia um I want to talk
briefly about this question of
partisanship right and we saw this a
little bit in the in the presidential
election in 2008 where frankly when when
it comes time to talking about being
concerned about Russia you know the old
white guy with a military background is
that an advantage and if that election
had contino for Russia Georgia war had
really been as important as some perhaps
hope you know that was one of the few
times that saw a bump for McCain but i
think this narrative that you know
Russians are Republicans are tough on
Russia and Democrats are weak is is not
really true and doesn't always hold up
under tighter
scrutiny I mean rush Republicans in
general are more hawkish on everything
right so so there's some truth to that
but but there's also more complicated
right the Bush administration was very
hawkish on Russia beginning kind of
early august of two thousand eight and
but and and between that time and before
that time the previous year's had a
policy that could either be described as
nuanced ters as being jenner if you were
being generous or confused if you were
not being generous but it wasn't
consistently hawkish similarly the
notion that that is gaining a fair
amount of currency in much of the region
that obama is kind of giving away the
shop is is a triumph i believe of
ideology over over over reality I'm
remaining moments here I want to talk a
little bit about how Russia seeks to
influence opinion here and this is part
of a broader question where a lot of
countries seek to influence opinion but
but the Russia story is interesting with
Russia today for example which is an
english-language television station
which I can imagine too many people
watch but I was there doing an interview
and I was watching beforehand that the
show they had about which was in a news
show in about America you know news in
the United States and in American
audiences and it was it was a reasonably
sophisticated very critical
left-of-center approach to American
politics of the kind that kind of
thoughtful American intellectuals would
have they probably wouldn't have it on a
television station you know that close
to the Russian government but the actual
message of what they were saying was not
too far off at all I want to briefly
tell another story about the Russia
Georgia war where I was going to go on
some television station you know to talk
about it and i e-mailed a bunch of a i
e-mailed a bunch of my friends in
california and said hey check this out
i'm going to be on CNN or whatever and
and one friend of mine who have known
forever and undoubtedly couldn't find
George and a map despite his oldest run
having lived there for two years emailed
me back with a set of talking points and
um which which on the one hand I was
impressed with the kind of hutzpah to
use a Georgian word but also I was
struck that the talking points were
straight out of Russian talking points
right now where had this kind of you
know okay I'm from San Francisco a
little bit different political spectrum
there but where had this guy
I was kind of acted in the San Francisco
anti-war movement found these talking
points right i mean on what website
amiens speak Russian and and it struck
me that and i would use and if you read
the comments section on any article
about georgia particularly in a kind of
american media huffington post and
things like that you know you get these
same talking points and we all know that
the comment section of the huffington
post in places like that are irrelevant
because these people are crazy right
three years ago they were so crazy that
they thought Hillary Clinton was not
going to win the Democratic nomination
for president and this obscure senator
from Illinois was so we know that that's
irrelevant it can be dismissed um I
think there's an important subtext of
how the united states have use Russia
which you can't say out loud right which
is that I regardless of what's one's
views are of the democratic credentials
of the Putin regime or the human rights
credentials of the Putin regime or the
respect for other borders that they're
of the Russian government there is a
certain Russian discomfort with its role
and an American discomfort with the
relationship with Russia as a regional
power the United States is a global
superpower perhaps Russia as a regional
superpower how does that work Russia is
is a bilateral relationship where has
expressed some discomfort with what what
what we say in the West as living with
kind of the new security agreements but
also what the rest the world understands
is living by America's rules and and
that's attention that's that's not going
to go away and the way that tension
represents itself often comes off a
sloppy or aggressive or or poorly
thought out but but but the chafing
there is real and and and the problems
that's going to raise our significant
the United States is not as is not
comfortable with anyone right with other
regional powers other regional powers
tend to play this more smoothly right
china for example is is certainly a
regional superpower to a far greater
extent in russia at this point but
doesn't doesn't isn't doesn't confront
that those sets of rules the same way
Russia does I think as we look at the
next ten years that's some people to
which we need to pay some attention
well as with any good panel agreements
disagreements but because time is short
instead of going to the panelists to
comment on each other's comments I think
wiser to go to you I hope a good mix of
elite and non-elite to pick up on
Lincoln Mitchell's thoughts so if you
would go to the mic and if you would
pose a question to one of the panelists
or if you just prefer to address it more
generally there is freedom in this room
okay my question is for the panel
general and is related to the WTO and
Russia we've seen that a few months ago
Russia has tried to access the route to
through custom union with Kazakhstan and
Belarus and now apparently just shifted
to a solo vid again so my question is
quite simple how do you see the chances
of Russia joining WTO in by the end of
the year the early 2011 and how will
that impact the US Russia political and
economical relation thank you very much
it was the last part of your question
the last thing you should how will it
impact an access to WTO will impact the
US and Russia relations thank you
next question well my wife's against the
WTO generally i don't feel strong what
about the other about it what interest
me though is the debate in rush i'm
really interested in the debates inside
Russia I don't think we in this country
who study Russia listen enough to
Russians debating among themselves or if
we hear it we don't take it seriously
for example everybody in the field in
this country knows that this new
modernization debate is broken out but
some people in the field dismiss it as
meaningless but it's not meaningless
Russia's had this debate every 50 or 60
years and it's had tremendous
consequences when they finally resolve
it usually not for the better but we
should pay attention we really should
the debate on the WTO in Russia is
interesting there is a very sizable
opinion in Russia against joining and
it's very pragmatic I leave aside the
ideological nutcase way that just
doesn't want to have anything to do with
the west and that is is that Russia's
essential industries are in ruins and
are in no position to face any kind of
Western competition whether we're
talking about chicken wings or
pharmaceuticals or automobiles or I
suppose any number of things that
Russian needs a period of protectionism
to get back on its feet now I'm now a
senior citizen but I can remember the
day when I was in college that we were
taught that that's correct that's what a
country should do that's been through a
great depression which Russia has been
we were given samuelson which was based
on how Roosevelt got America out of the
depression or thought he did the war
helped but now we are there the
different economic orthodoxy in the
world which is a kind of monitor
snowboarder orthodoxy but there are
people in Russia who believe Russia is
simply not ready and then there's a
group that believes that it will abet
Russia's modernization by German joining
the
WTO and this is one of these situations
I think that if we're objective both
sides are right it's a balancing act for
Russia ideally Russia would come in with
certain exemptions and conditions but
that may not be permitted but it's a
major major major decision for Russia as
a future economic power which it wants
to be beyond being a supplier of energy
of whether joining the WTO will a bet or
prevent Russia becoming such an economic
power and I don't know the answer
Russians will have to decide but I think
that's part of the reason why one day
Putin's for it in the next days not four
and yet if send forth and you silent
that they've got advisers tugging them
in opposite directions it's a very
important decision for them
I was somewhat intrigued by the comment
that Russia is a western country from
what i have read russia's sphere of
influence at least is working towards
embracing its neighbors like china japan
particularly in view of the fact that
there is so much distrust in the Western
about Russia's intentions for the future
and we see Donnell's every day that you
look at the Obama's administration
towards what some of us are proud to
call a liberalization process here and
all you get is Oh socialism on its track
we try to avoid that the notion of the
Cold War intrigue store are still with
us my question would be how do we get
beyond it well first of all if we talk
about socialism by the way there was
also Western concept so Russia is a
western country that doesn't want to be
one it accepts adopts Western concepts
but then turn them into something that
is as Steven Cohen so eloquently talked
about a Eurasian and I think that is a
huge Russia problem is that sort of
geography that is that is stuck with but
ultimately in throughout all Russian
history it has been strides towards
becoming a western country and then when
things don't work out really well or
fast enough Russia fell back to what it
called Russian asst which almost
basically nothing that is to say there
was no such thing because we talked
about China if we talk about Asia if we
talk about Middle East we talk about
countries that have specific values that
are that those cultural values of that
particular nation geography and whatnot
and this is actually humongously long
conversation so just finish with the
fact that all Russian values if we talk
about the values particularly it's what
the West is not and that by definition
if there is no other definition makes it
a western country because Russia defines
itself to what the West is not so it is
a western country or the unrest or west
with a negative something and when I
talk about the value is just a few
examples you know it's charity in Russia
justice and the West it's a practicality
in the West Des spirituality in Russia
and what not and you can actually lists
list them all but that what really from
my point of view defines Russia as a
western country
problem is is that nina krilova is
russian and i was born in kentucky so
it's not ready for me to say Russia's of
the West or not if she insists that it
is then I suppose it is all i can say is
that's not my experience I'd have a hard
time making such a generalization
knowing that there's 20 million Islamic
citizens in the Russian Federation with
knowing that Russia being the largest
country in the world even after the end
of the Soviet state I think about
two-thirds of its borders or with
non-western countries first and foremost
China and so forth I personally think
it's good thing that Russia doesn't know
if it's of the East or the west it's a
debate that's going on I guess when did
it again sometime in the 17th 18th
century it came to a peak in the 19th
century I think that's a good thing for
a country to constantly asked questions
about itself it may become dysfunctional
miss nina says some time but i don't
think we asked enough countries have
enough questions about ourselves here
it's not a bad thing Russians are very
smart and I think if we leave them alone
they'll figure it out and some mix of
east and west probably would suit him
just fine why not take the best of both
but they're not sure that it's been
going the debates been going on for
centuries so I can't say I I know that
nobody asked me but i was i was born in
New York so I'm gonna give you my two
cents anyway this question seems to me
is is is a question that I don't I don't
really think it's I don't really get the
question not-not-not don't get the ideas
because there's an enormous swath of the
world which SWAT which begins somewhere
just east of Greek east of Greece and
ends somewhere just west of Xian in
China where you know this question of
our way in the Western I'm exaggerating
a little bit are we in the West or are
we in the East right there are many
countries and the Balkans and the
Caucasus where we talked about being
both west and east and and and because
of that these terms take on you know
less less meaning I mean China adapted a
Western ideology right and
you know the dung years talked about
socialism with Chinese characteristics
right i think if we define China as a
western country based on that criteria
you kind of have to recognize that the
whole world is a Western place right so
so I I don't have an answer the question
i'm not i'm not going to weigh in on
that but i don't know that it's a
particularly i know this is me being not
someone who studies russia because i
assumed if you study russia you agonize
over this question but but but for me
it's not a particular interest it's not
really useful question because the
answers don't necessarily lead you
anywhere my question relates to Russian
perspectives on US policy and US
perspectives on Russian policy in these
two instances does Russia have a policy
toward Afghanistan and is there a whiff
of schadenfreude with respect to the
u.s. wrestling over the issue and from
the US point of view has the u.s. been
sufficient given the fact that great
powers have force fields that is to say
territory in there along their immediate
borders in which they feel they have
privileged access has the u.s. been
sufficiently sensitive to Russian policy
requirements let's say in those areas or
has it been pushing the envelope thank
you regards the ladder I think that's it
certainly a a area of some contention
between the United States and Russia
because the United States certainly
doesn't recognize that and has kind of
over and over said that it doesn't
recognize that particularly with
countries that don't want that don't
want the warm embrace of Russia so that
that is a very serious issue between the
two countries and it's not likely to
change the only times it'll change is
when countries you know if there's been
a country that is a warm feeling with
Russia is not an issue but you know for
a country like Georgia or Ukraine at
times that's absolutely something that
the United States that does not
recognize and has made clear over and
over there doesn't recognize regards to
your first question I don't know I mean
I think that Russia and is important for
the Afghan war effort for the United
States side because we fly over Russian
territory get stuff there and because if
Russia wants to disrupt any kind of
transit transportation routes it can do
that reasonably effectively um III don't
know the more profound
of the Russian attitude towards the
American project there on a kind of more
more abstract level I can't I can't
speak to I would be you know we all we
all know that that I mean on the one
hand we all know that you know every
Empire has tried to take over
Afghanistan and has failed and that's
kind of part of the popular narrative on
Afghanistan on the other hand the United
States military was able to go into
reasonably quickly it just hasn't really
found what to do next you know you know
we have in the room somebody who
probably has a much better knowledge and
grasp on these questions and who really
ought to be up here and I hope he'll
speak up as Professor former ambassador
students istana bitch because he's been
involved in these both as a policy maker
and as a intellectual and he probably is
closer to he probably hears more closely
what people say in Washington possibly
in Moscow my impression is and I hope
Steve will speak up is first of all
those Russians who matter want us to win
the war in Afghanistan though they be
hard put to say just as we are what it
means to win the war in Afghanistan but
they would like Russians to stabilize
Afghanistan because in a way their stake
in a catastrophic situation Afghanistan
is much greater than ours their stake is
they see it is the spread of Islamic
radicalism into Central Asia which is
Russia's backyard and what has already
happened the torrential flow of opium
heroin narcotics across Russia from
Afghanistan now having said that they do
not fully agree with the way the United
States is conducting the war in
Afghanistan though they are divided they
think first that we have not learned the
lessons of the Soviet defeat in
Afghanistan which by the way they don't
think was a defeat they make yeltsin
abandoned a stable regime after the
soviet withdrawal and that that regime
should have been supported that's their
view secondly they think the United
States is not doing enough
to put it into the flow of opium out of
out of Afghanistan into Central Asia and
thirdly they're very very suspicious of
Americans political intentions in
Afghanistan because when they they being
Putin after 911 help the American land
war against the Taliban more than any
other nay NE more than any NATO country
did they thought they'd be rewarded by a
say in the Kabul government and they
were excluded so they are suspicious of
us what they want us to win a second
answer to your question is Russia's
perception of our policy both Medvedev
and Putin have said using exactly the
same words and Steve may have been there
in Washington when metaph was there
about 18 months ago speaking to the
council and he used this word and I'm
Madeleine Albright was presiding or
something he said we feel deceived and
betrayed deceived in betrayed by
American policy first that's not a good
way to begin a reset relationship we
need to know why they feel that way what
did we do we need to ask that question
and answer it so the answer is they were
very unhappy with American policy toward
Russia since the end in Soviet Union and
to end to my way of thinking though
Lincoln said that a new Cold War's a
cliche and I made it the subtitle of my
recent book that if there has been a new
Cold War or a continuing Cold War the
essential question the existential
question is this question of a Russian
sphere of influence in the former Soviet
territories are they entitled to it or
are they not entitled to it now
reflexively we say they're not entitled
to it because it's not democratic it's
not just it doesn't respect the rights
of other nations to self-determination
and we don't do it but all those
statements are false we do do it and I
would just leave you with this forward
what is the
expansion of NATO other than an
expansion of the American sphere of
influence to Russia's borders we are
saying to Russia and we have been saying
to them since NATO expansion began what
used to be your sphere of influence is
now ours that's what we're saying that's
what they think we're saying I think
that is what we're saying now the only
way to reconcile yourself to this
American position is to say good nestle
it should be we're good there bad and
this is virtuous or to say something's
gone wrong here this is a dual standard
it's dangerous it contributed to the
what what what Lincoln called the
russian-georgian war I call it a
russian-american war in Georgia is very
dangerous and American we decide to
decide as a policymaking nation what our
position on this is because the Russian
CS is either exceedingly hypocritical or
as kind of pursuing an evil with their
expense but this is the issue and
everybody should take a stand on it does
Russia have an entitlement to have some
sphere of influence on its border now we
could debate what that would mean but i
would say they are entitled at a minimum
to have countries free of foreign bases
on their borders at a minimum and I
think we on several thought might be
able to live with that formulation of a
sphere of influence everybody my name is
monsoon on the student at GS Colombia so
I at first I want to say i was born in
Uzbekistan and I think that Russia is a
western country atlases must be a
western country so I'm on the same page
with me for sure I have two short
questions so number one it's what do you
thing about demographic problem in
Russia because Russia is just dying
right now mr. show told that it's 140
million 140 million people there so for
such vast country it's nothing it should
be at least 23 times more so what do you
think about this problem is it really
serious and what Russia should do about
it and number two as I heard
but Putin you know I'm starting here one
year and it happened i'm waiting when
columbia is going to invite Putin here
so identify her address this to you I
don't know to ask Harmon Institute or
somebody to invite booting to Columbia
thank you he actually spoke here about
six years ago I guess he was president
right now they can invite him as price-
I think McVeigh def is probably a better
speaker actual I needs the president um
he's the president yes he's the
president well the demographics it's
it's a serious problem it's a growing
problem it's a country and I keep going
back to this so I'm not going to dwell
on this it's country that can that
cannot really take care of itself it
does do the military-industrial complex
it does do the great Russian nation oil
and gas and whatnot but it really cannot
take care of itself it cannot take care
of its 11 now it's nine time zones
territory and so all the social issues
are rising to the surface and I actually
think that that's why there have been
steps towards liberalization because
they really have to start taking care of
of this kind of problems and once again
in the Western thank you very much for
supporting me and by the way your great
friend may have Gorbachev would totally
agree with me in fact she actually your
great friend me how Gorbachev would
totally agree with me in fact as you may
remember i think in malta there was a
there was a little bit of disagreement
because they were talking about Western
values and Gorbachev said oh no there's
a human values so here well that
clinched it um we have two more
questions here and then if ambassador
sis Donovan would like to say a few
words please please do so sometimes it
is said that when Russian leaders speak
of modernization it's a code word for
redistribution of wealth what does the
Russian elite think of meta
modernization efforts and do they think
is pledges to and legal nihilism is
substantive or just window dressing so
far it has been just a talk on the legal
nihilism and I actually used the example
of how their koffsky because I think
it's the most what the many glaring but
this is one of the most glaring one of
one other example as you know that the
incredible cases just unbearable cases
of militsia police brutality that has
been promised to be investigated and and
so far the cases are getting worse and
worse and worse and it is really
happened because early on in Putin's
leadership he basically said to Scylla
Vicky which is the kind of military
military industrial complex forces the
power ministry force is saying well you
know Russia is yours you do what you
need to do so that they started taking
care of this they try to take care of
this but I don't really know how long it
will take and web invasives rhetoric
will eventually turn into into actually
interactions could I just say one thing
on that front Nina knows well the
history of dual power in Soviet history
Russian history it is true that there
are more words than deeds but President
Medvedev speech anti Stalinist speech
which was on his vlog if you can believe
this he does a video blog some Russians
have compared it to Khrushchev secret
speeches speech in 1961 is the most
serious anti Stalinist speech of course
Gorbachev gave many but never completely
devoted to this issue and I recommend
anyone here to go find it it was October
thirtieth and also I just add that by
giving his first print interview to
Novaya Gazeta again only words but it
has offered that newspaper which is
always under fire in many ways a measure
of
action now this indeed actually changing
but there wasn't his speech though it
was just his blog he did talk about it
in bits and pieces but he wasn't they
never nobody has ever yet went out and
said it has been the problem styling
this was a problem they just put it in
which is which is amazing could you say
could you say that again nobody's ever
done what nobody it was in his speech it
was actually a blog and we know that
what you said nobody's ever done what
nobody has given a speech on stalinism
yet nobody in I mean in those people at
the current current icon administer no
of course they have it has been done but
not the current administration which I'm
not I'm not diminishing the effort the
woman who raised the question about
modernization and wealth Oh deserves an
answer because I to my mind's very smart
question Russia has a property problem I
think I think it's the major problem
blocking progress as we would understand
it in the country think about it like
this in 1917 the wealth of the gentry
and the middle class was confiscated
first by the peasants then by the
Bolsheviks then in 1929 the wealth of a
peasant the land was confiscated by
Stalin then after 1991 state property
was confiscated by the men gathered
around Yeltsin that's a lot of property
confiscation in one century and each
time it's left bitter bitter almost
irreconcilable political divisions in
the country it bears today on
modernization because every public
opinion poll confirms that roughly
seventy percent of those surveyed people
surveyed believe that the big property
that's held privately in Russia today
was it obtained illicitly and his
illegitimate
and that's why the financial elite will
never prohibit democracy in Russia for
democracy you need a representative
Parliament if it was a truly represented
Parliament they take that property away
from those people so now that if
modernization debate comes up and this
property question is arisen again what
are you going to do about all that
property that is at least formally
however much the state still controls it
viewed as a legitimate but nor billions
and billions and burns and billions of
assets in private hands one view is you
take it away from these people and you
put it back where it was in the hands of
the state and the state uses it to
modernize Russia that's always done
another view says no you bring that what
they call euphemistically the business
community this financial elite along as
a modernizing agent but then the other
side says that the financially has no
vested interest in the modernizing
project because they would diminish that
modernizing elite dependence on energy
and existing assets and so it goes but
you're absolutely right that the
question of modernization once again is
about what to do with property and
whether to redistribute it or ratify it
and here to the country's divided I
walked in just as you someone was saying
and Obama has given away the ship and
I'm not clear whether the speaker
believe that or didn't and my other
question is what's happening since the
Moscow bombings I have the Chechens been
further rounded up I see we seem to have
heard very little about this thank you
very much um what I said was that the
the narrative that Obama has given away
the ship is a triumph of ideology over
fact so I was not saying that he had
given away it's not true that was what I
think that's what the Chechen situation
may be
in addition to that as well going to
give him the cheshire please come up
here please I don't know if anyone on
this panel one on the chechen thank you
i thought this is a really interesting
panel and i want to commend the the
panelists and also hold on a second want
to commend the issue because there's a
lot of interesting stuff in here and
everyone will benefit from reading it
you know when putin was here he was
can't remember exactly when he spoke in
low library the most interesting
question he was asked was someone said
could you talk to us about freedom of
the press in russia and he said well we
don't have freedom of the press in
Russia so you you do hear interesting
things when when you get when you get
Russian leaders to to talk and I
actually agree with with Steve on this
the the discussion that is the implicit
dialogue and debate going on between
Putin Nevada is highly significant just
to take one of your the issue that you
raised most recently Steve the question
of property and modernization you know
Putin had a solution to this which was
to take it back to the state and
Medvedev has said State corporations
have no place in the modern world you
know it's maybe they'll figure out some
way to reconcile those two points of
view but I would consider that to be a
pretty diametric disagreement and one
that makes it pretty significant who is
president after the 2012 elections these
are real political stakes and real
material stakes that
and in play in an election of that sort
only problem is we don't really know how
the election is going to be conducted
one of the things that you will learn if
you read there this issue I'd suggest
one place one thing you definitely don't
want to miss is Sergei rep coughs
interview because he has an interesting
little tug of war with the interviewer
from the journal who keeps asking him
you know aren't russian-american
relations really terrible just terrible
deteriorated in crisis all this and he
keeps saying well I don't know you're
talking about now some of this is
official boilerplate and you don't
always believe what a deputy foreign
minister says but pay attention he's not
he's rejecting the the point of view
that there's a kind of that
russian-american relations are on a
collision course he says oh you know
we've got so much to do so much business
to transact and I think that's worth
paying attention to because it seems to
me right now today the ascendant theme
in russian foreign policy i don't know
what will come of it but i would watch
that space i've been predicting for
about three four years that
russian-american relations were bound to
improve under any new administration and
and I and it wouldn't have mattered
really who won the election that would
have happened and I think the Russians
are interested in doing it now what
we've seen this before russian-american
relations improve at the beginning of
new Russian presidencies and new
American presidencies you had a kind of
commitment by Yeltsin and Clinton to a
cooperative relationship which
deteriorated over time not steadily
buddy by the end of the administration
it was not in a good place the bush and
Putin presidencies began in a somewhat
similar way an interest a palpable
interest on the part of both
of them to seek a new relationship that
would be a kind of repudiation of their
predecessors by the way I wrote a little
peaceful about this called the unclean
t'en and the onion sent and I think they
both wanted to pursue that and they did
in in some ways the high point
historically and i don't mean since the
end of the Cold War I mean of all times
in russian-american relations was 2002a
you know people were talking about an
alliance but that deteriorated too so
history tells you expect a good
relationship between rush in the United
States at the beginning of presidencies
and then watch out watch what happens
try to understand what the dynamics are
that are producing a different result
let me just say couple of things about
Afghanistan since there was a specific
question here and I was invited up to
answer that one if you read Sergey rev
kev you will read the astonishing claim
that the United States cannot leave
Afghanistan without Russia's permission
and puts it slightly differently he says
the Security Council has to authorize
the withdrawal of the forces that it is
approved of the international mandate
can't just be exercised by the United
States he says we want you there we want
you there of course you need to go at
some point but we want you there to
achieve your mission that's part of the
broad theme of cooperation that he that
he sounds but the Russians are as Steve
and others have said deeply conflicted
about this enterprise they they've been
there and done that and it didn't go
well and the fact that they have never
proposed to have any troops there the
fact that you had to get to 2009 before
overflights were authorized shows you
how
they've wanted to be from this from this
enterprise I remember being in Moscow to
the end of two thousand for
consultations with the Russian
government foreign ministry about a
Security Council resolution on the
Taliban and we also had discussions
about the Northern Alliance and how the
Northern Alliance could be strengthened
and the prospective arms supplies to the
Northern Alliance and the Russians were
talking about how this would of course
be a possibility but I realized at a
certain point in our discussion that we
weren't too clear about who was going to
pay for the arms and they said well
they're going to pay we're not doing
this for free you know so there's a and
that tends to be a kind of mismatch that
continues there are many opportunities
for Russian economic engagement in
Afghanistan the rehabilitation of most
of the industrial plant would be much
easier for the Russians to undertake
then for any other country and in fact
Western companies have been involved in
trying to rehab those plants and has
been gone very well I understand from
friends of mine on the ground partly
because the you know there's not a real
interoperability there and they say to
me you know why don't we have the
Russians here well one question is who
would pay and that's a you know that's a
big question in in all politics Steve's
theme about opium is of course very very
important Russians are conscious of the
the price that they have paid for the
resurgence of opium production in in
Afghanistan I don't think we are they
have very good answers to that though so
it's a it's the sort of thing that can
provide a lot of cooperative dialogue
but if you look at Plan Colombia you
don't exactly get the sense that we've
got a blueprint for for solving this
problem let me just say one last thing
about some of the discussion here about
different viewpoints in
in Russia and when we rethink Russia we
often elevate these ideas and then set
them at war with each other we say you
know there's this view and there's this
view and maybe there's some times of you
in between and they have to fight it out
and you know that's a kind of handy
shorthand but political scientists and
and I think it's very useful to try to
capture the mindset of some of the
participants in Russian politics by
assigning them to one or another of
these points of view but politics is not
about groups of ideas at war with each
other often is also about the struggle
of institutions interest groups
individuals and I think to have a full
picture of what's going on in Russia we
actually have to begin to attach these
ideas to those institutions some of them
divided some of those interest groups
some of those individuals we talked a
little bit about Putin and Medvedev who
seemed to me to be individuals who have
begun to express rather different ideas
as part of their political competition I
think if you begin to look at what the
approaches taken in different
institutions interest groups by
different individuals you see I I think
one of the particular values that comes
out of that is a different approach here
I disagree bit with Steve to the United
States because I believe lots there are
there is a view within cano with in
Russian interest groups within Russian
institutions with among individual
political leaders that assigns a
different role to the United States from
from the one that that Steve is set
forth that does not at all think the
United States is finished and our future
is with Berlin the Russians have been
reading the Financial Times recently
about the euro and the European Union
and when I go to Moscow I never hear
anything to it about the European Union
so the Europe as a horse is one that
Russians don't understand don't respect
don't it have a really easy time
interacting with it's not a nation-state
and they're in the phase of nation-state
consciousness and as they sometimes say
in some not in so many words to us so
are you so there's a kind of easier
interaction between Russia in the United
States than there is between Russia and
and Europe and I would say even between
Russia and Germany I think you could
make the same judgment about China but
you'd have to add the further element
which is fear and I'll really let it go
at that if you take a broad picture of
Russian interests and in interest groups
and institutions you'd sort of find you
find different views of the United
States and greater receptivity to
cooperation because they think they're
things that the United States can
provide and I'll just give one tiny
example that nobody else can about half
the Russian government came to Cambridge
in January for a kind of summit with
anybody know about this who's her who
knows about this with the MIT faculty
you know because that was where they
wanted to conduct their discussion about
modernization for them that debate about
the future their country is one that
they can conduct in a more meaningful in
full way in of all places or on of all
places the Charles River Nina said we
could go on and on and on talking about
all this I won't thank you very much
Thank You ambassador sis Donovan for
those wonderful closing remarks and
thank you panelists for your pluralism
of views in a civil and engaging and
informative way civility is to be prized
in our discourse these days thank you